cinderella has arrived
cinderella do you think it could be
sweaty or ella
is it a little sweaty under there it's a
little bit mice i'm not gonna lie i'll
tell you underneath this jacket all
kinds of scary things are happening but
there's a family of dead people under
here they've died with the heat
okay
you guys are here again you were the
belle of the ball last year and you guys
partied you said the ladies were in a
cut-up this year i mean seriously this
i can't actually believe that i'm in the
gaggle again i honestly i thought i was
one and done and
didn't even think i'd be nominated this
year
i'm gonna tell you the show is so
fantastic
salmon rebecca come on where does this
go what happened what can you tell me
give me something i'm not gonna lie that
wasn't a hard day at the office
for either of us we were like oh god
okay
it came across on the screen the fun of
it you know i was like damn they are
this is real i mean to the point where
when they're moving cameras around
they're like do you want to go into the
green room and we were like no
we're good okay standing here in the bed
we're good we're good okay i want to ask
you are you guys you're filming right
now will you pause for the queen will
you pause i paused for the queen and we
are pausing for the queen yeah i was i
was absolutely i was shell-shocked at
how deeply upset i was and i couldn't
get myself together at all
yeah she's she's um she's been part of
our lives she's like a grandmother to us
the greatest states person that has ever
lived well to say that transition now to
king charles iii is the thing that many
people
feared some are excited but many are
feared
i i i only fear for him in terms of the
weight that he has on his shoulders now
you know he's he's still sprightly man
but he's 73 and it's an awful lot to
follow i think he's got it um but it's
it's a it's a lot and we must not forget
that he is a human first in his morning
mourning his beloved mother